we got a bunch of news from today's
ubisoft forward with both new games and
the return of some old favorites
scott pilgrim and prince of persia are
coming back and we learned about
immortals phoenix rising
i'm chastity and this is your save save
for thursday september 10.
after a bunch of rumors and hints
ubisoft finally confirmed that scott
pilgrim vs the world the game is coming
back
get ready to fight those evil x's and
rock out on the base the game based on
the original graphic novels by brian lee
o'malley not the movie released in 2010
but was delisted in 2014 so there's been
no way to buy it since then to celebrate
the game's 10th anniversary we're
getting the complete edition
which includes the original game and all
of its dlc you can play with up to four
players locally or online as well as
compete in subspace minigames like
dodgeball
it's coming to current gen consoles pc
and stadia this holiday for 15
there's no exact date or word about
next-gen consoles yet
prince of persia the sans of time is
getting a remake and it's coming early
next year
the sands of time remake is coming to
ps4 xbox one and pc on january 21st 2021
this is a complete remake from the
ground up with yuri lowenthal returning
to voice the prince again
the game's visuals combat and camera
have been overhauled there's a new enemy
targeting system that quote enhances the
velocity of the prince and his ability
to do amazing moves
the original 1989 game is also included
as an unlockable
the remake costs 40 us dollars and
pre-orders include some in-game bonuses
the game formerly known as gods and
monsters is now called immortals phoenix
rising and it's launching this year
it's an open world action adventure game
set in greek mythology you play as
phoenix a new winged demigod who has to
save four greek gods in different
regions overtaken by mythological
monsters
it's coming to ps4 ps5 xbox one series x
and s
pc and stadia this year on december 3rd
there will also be a demo exclusively on
stadia the demo is free and all you need
is a gmail account to try it out
and that's just some of the news that
came from today's ubisoft forward for
more including watch dogs legion and
rainbow six siege
check out all of our coverage on
gamespot and that's your save save for
today what game are you most excited
about let me know on twitter at chastity
underscore v or let me know in the
comments down below stay safe and i'll
see you next time
you